no matter what anybody says you can say
seems like you had a reason for saying
that like no matter what they say I hate
you and everything you stand for seems
like you got a reason for saying that
it's
disarming they'll talk with you about it
I want to do business with you and I
want to deal with you right now seems
like I had a reason for saying it well
yeah here's why I want to do business
with you the more you encourage the
other side to talk the more like it is
that you're going to get to this moment
of collaboration quicker never be so
sure of what you want that you wouldn't
take something better how do you get
something better you get the other side
to talk you spend a lot less time
talking and appreciate that they're
bringing something to the table that you
could use the Black Swan the tiny little
things is going to change everything you
trigger that you're going to make great
deals